NOTICES NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM. SERGEANT SERGEANT
REPAIR THE CHAMBER BRING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. I AGREE ARE
CURRY IRAN BELA POWER QUE HAN
BERMAN BIGELOW. BLOOM BURNER
HORVATH. BONTA BROUGH BURKE.
CALLED AROUND CORREO SERVAN
SAYS CHILD CAN DAVID YOU SHOW A
CANTON TO COOL LEE COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DEEP.
EIGHT MEN LAURA FONG FRASIER
FREEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CHRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIVES IN GLORIA GUNS ALL IS
GREAT GREY SEDAN HOLDEN- WHEN
JONES LAWYER. ALL RIGHT THE
CAMEL AUGER HI LEE LACKEY LEVIN
LIMO OWN LOW MAIN SHINE MATT
THIS MAZE MCCARTY MEDINA
MELENDEZ MULLEN MERCY G.
MISSOURIAN OVER **** O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PEACHTREE NORRIS
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA. ROM LOS
RAYOS LOSE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SOLACE
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE SEEING THE
PAL WALDRON WEBER WAKES WOULD
MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS ACORN
IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT
IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASKED THAT
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY. PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. THE DAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PATTY
OSHA RECORD OF. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A MOMENT OF REFLECTION. FROM
THE TIME I WAS VERY YOUNG. MANY
OF MY FAMILY AND FRIENDS WE
BEGIN THE NEW YEAR MAKING A
PERSONAL NEW YEAR'S RESOLUTION.
MOST I CANNOT EVEN REMEMBER NOW
BUT FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS MY
RESOLUTION HAS REMAINED THE
SAME IT IS THIS. LET ME TRY TO
LIVE EACH DAY OF THIS NEW YEAR
WITH MORE PATIENCE GRATITUDE
AND KINDNESS. LET ME NOT FORGET
THAT FROM THE MOMENT WE ARE
BORN THERE IS NO GUARANTEE OF
EVEN ONE MORE DAY OF LIFE. EACH
DAY IS A GIFT THAT I MUST TRY
TO LIVE AS BEST I CAN. IN THE
YEAR AHEAD LET US ALL TRY TO
EMBRACE EACH NEW DAY WITH OPEN
MINDS AND WARM HEARTS. THOUGH
THIS TRY TO WAKE UP EACH DAY
HAPPY TO BE ALIVE AND SLEEP
EACH NIGHT GRATEFUL FOR THE DAY.
NOW MOMMY DON'T SOON WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. THANK YOU REVEREND WE
ASKED OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KOREA. AS SHE
LEAVES US IN THE PLEDGE THE
SCREEN. PUT YOUR RIGHT HAND
OVER YOUR HEART. READY AGAIN. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES. ZERO OKAY
ONE IS ABLE. TO ACCESS ALL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING IN THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY NOVEMBER
TWELFTH 2019% OF THE PROVISIONS
OF JOINT RULE THIRTY NINE THE
FOLLOWING ITS ONLY JOURNAL FOR
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION WAS PRINTED
WHILE THE FAMILY WAS AN INTERIM
STUDY RECESS THE POINT
COMMUNICATION FIRST PRESENTED
BY THE ASSISTANT CHIEF CLERK IN
ORDER TO PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. MR CALDERONE MOVES AND
MS WALDRON SECONDS. AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS HAVE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE THE BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED RED AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVIE TWO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THE ABSENCE IS FOR
THE DAY. FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SABRINA SERVAN CASE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILIP CHAN
.
MEMBERS. THANK YOU MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO MR
CALL THE ROUND WELCOME BACK MR
CALDERONE YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURE MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SPEND A
SAMUEL ONE EIGHTEEN AID TO
ALLOW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOSE
REAVIS AS WELL AS A FAMILY
MEMBER ON BURKE HAD GUESSING
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROUTE REVERSES
GUEST WILL BE AT HER DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SPEND SEVERAL FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
SOMETHING MEMBERS CALLED ROOM.
GLORIA GONZALES SMITH AND WOULD
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY. AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH UP WITH THE ORDER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
STRIKE ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
TO NINETY FIVE DAILY FROM THE
FILE. WITHOUT OBJECTION SO
SHALL BE THE ORDER PURSUANT TO
IS ONLY ONE NINETY SIX A
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
REFER TO THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. A B. TWO SEVEN SIX
FREEMAN FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE A B. NINE FIFTY THREE
TAKING. FROM THE BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE A. B. TEN SEVENTY ONE
THE MOAN FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND- A B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX ROMMEL'S FROM THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH UP WITH THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RETURN ITEM NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY FIVE FORTY FIVE LOW
TO THE SENATE FOR FURTHER
ACTION. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
REQUESTING THEM CONSENT TO
ORDER H. R. SIXTY EIGHT I.
MISTER SPEAKER TO THE THIRD
READING FILE TO BE TAKEN ON
THURSDAY AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SUCH UP WITH THE
ORDER
. MEMBERS OF MY CAN I HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION. MEMBERS THANK
YOU HAVE YOUR ATTENTION. PLEASE
DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. MISTER
SPEAKER. HAS A FEW WORDS FOR S.
MEMBERS YOUR ATTENTION PLEASE.
MISTER SPEAKER ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MIGHT STAFF TELLS ME I
DO WELCOME SPEECH EVERY YEAR I
DON'T REMEMBER EVER DOING THE
WELCOME SPEECH SO I ASSUME
THEY'RE MESSING WITH ME BUT
IT'LL BE SHORT AND SWEET. LAST
YEAR WE PRODUCED SOME BILLS
THAT HAD A TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON
THE STATE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE A TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE
STATE IN YEARS TO COME. I'M
EAGER TO SEE THE LEGISLATION
THAT THESE MEMBERS PUT FORTH
THIS YEAR. AS WE MAKE THE
TRANSITION FROM NINETY TWO FROM
FROM NINETEEN NINETEEN WE'RE
TRANSITIONING FROM NINETEEN
NINETY ONE. FROM TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TO TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
LET'S MOVE CAREFULLY AND WITH
CONSIDERATION BUT ALSO BOLDLY
AND AMBITIOUSLY. AS WE AS WE
GET GO IN THIS YEAR WE ONE OF
THE THINGS WE NEED TO DO IS GET
OUR- GET OUR HOUSE IN ORDER IN
A NUMBER OF WAYS- TO THIS POINT
WE WILL BE INSTALLING A NEW.
CHIEF CLERK. SUE PARKER WHO WE
ALL KNOW. AND A NEW CHIEF
SURGEON ARMS WHO AM I HOPE A
LOT OF YOU'VE INTRODUCED
YOURSELF TO A LISA BUCKLEY. AT
THURSDAY'S SESSION WE WILL HOLD
OUR FORMAL VOTE ON THESE TWO
WELCOME ADDITIONS THESE SIMPLY
TEAM. I DON'T MUCH I DON'T HAVE
MUCH ELSE TO SAY AT THE MOMENT
ASIDE FROM WHEN I STARTED WITH
WHICH IS WELCOME AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. AT
THIS TME I WOULD LIKE TO ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY
CONGRATULATE MISTER BRIAN MAIN
SHINE ON HIS ENGAGEMENT OVER
THE HOLIDAYS. MEMBERS WE HAVE
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY. AND I WAS JUST
INFORMED IT'S MR MCCARTY'S
BIRTHDAY TODAY SIR. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MISTER MCCARTY. AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER'S
BIRTHDAY WAS YESTERDAY HAVE
YOUR BIRTHDAY MISTER COOPER.
AND MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY. MISTER
PATTERSON I BELIEVE YOUR GUESTS
ARE IN THE GALLERY THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER OP AND A MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE DEANNA
ALAN- SHE IS ACCOMPANIED BY HER
DAUGHTER KENZIE. AND A GROUP OF
EXCHANGE IS FROM SPAIN FRANCE
AND LITHUANIA THEY'RE ALL
ATTENDING HIGH SCHOOL IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN VARIOUS PARTS
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY AS PART
OF THE FUTURE LEADERS EXCHANGE
PROGRAM PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM TO OUR ASSEMBLY.
AND MS REMUS YOU HAVE A VERY
SPECIAL GUEST ON THE FLOOR WITH
YOU TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M VERY
EXCITED TO HAVE MY NEPHEWS
ERICA NICHOLAS ROMMEL'S JOINING
ME ON THE FLOOR TODAY AND
THEY'LL BE HERE ALL WEEK WITH
ME- THEY ARE FROM LANCASTER
CALIFORNIA- ERIC IS A JUNIOR AT
CAL STATE MONTEREY BAY. AND
NICHOLAS IS NOT TENTH GRADER SO
THANK YOU PLEASE COME BY AND
SAY HELLO TO THEM THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. ON
CAN CURRENTS FILE AND NUMBER
ONE PASSING RETAIN ON
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS ONE
TWENTY ONE THROUGH ONE TWENTY
FIVE ARE TO BE CONTINUED. THAT
BRINGS US TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. FILE ITEMS ONE
TWENTY SIX ONE TWENTY SEVEN.
AND ONE TWENTY EIGHT PASSER
RETAIN. NUMBERS THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE AT A ONE TWENTY NINE.
THAT IS A B. FIFTEEN OH SIX FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORKERY WITH AMENDMENTS AS ON
THE BILL FIFTEEN OH SIX WITH
THE MEMONS BY FAMILY MEMBER
MCCARTY. MEMBERS. PLEASE GIVE
ATTENTION TO THE BIRTHDAY BOY
MISTER MCCARTY ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU I AGAIN
THIS IS FOR A PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENT SAYS AS A B. FIFTEEN
OH SIX IT USED TO BE RELATED TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS IT IS NO LONGER
RELATED CHARTER SCHOOLS I
REPEAT IS NO LONGER RELATED TO-
CHARTER SCHOOL REGULATION
CALIFORNIA IT'S A CLEAN AT BILL
RELATE TO OUR OUR GREEN
RESTAURANT ACT FROM LAST YEAR
AND- AGAIN THIS PERPER PURPOSE
THE MINUTES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MCCARTY. SEE NO
DISCUSSION ON THE AMENDMENT SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES HAVE
IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILLS OUT THE PRINCE. AND
BACK ON FILE IN PURSUANT TO US
SIMPLY ROLL SEVENTY SEVEN POINT
TWO. I AM RE REFERRING ITEM ONE
TWENTY NINE AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
MCCARTY TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. WELL I ONE
THIRTY PASS TO RETAIN A SENATOR
READING FILE ITEMS ONE THIRTY
ONE THROUGH ONE THIRTY THREE.
PASS AND RETAIN. IN THE ABSENCE
OF OBJECTION. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY
. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS WE'RE AT
A GERMAN TO MEMORY PLEASE GIVE
YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO
YOUR COLLEAGUES. MEMBERS IN THE
CENTER AISLE. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
WHERE THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS
.
MEMBERS. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
WHERE THE GERMANS TO MEMORY
.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION
TO MR CALL THE WRONG MR CALL
THE RUN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR A GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
IN TODAY- I RISE WITH THREE
INDIVIDUALS THAT I'M GONNA BE A
TURNING IN MEMORY OF- THREE
FORMER MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
OFFERS IS CHARLES WARREN WHO-
WAS IN THE HOLLYWOOD AREA AND
HE SERVED FROM NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE TO NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN- WHILE SERVING IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY FROM
SIXTY THREE TO SEVENTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARNED
DEVELOPED THE FIRST THE U. S.
STATE WIDE NINE ONE ONE
EMERGENCY TECH- TELEPHONE
SERVICE PROGRAM. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARNED WAS ALSO A STRONG
PROPONENT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES GOING ON TO HOLD A
CABINET LEVEL POSITION AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE COUNCIL ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY UNDER
PRESIDENT JIMMY CARTER FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE AND
SERVED A TWO YEAR TERM AS A
SPEAKER AS- A SPEAKER WILLIE
BROWN APPOINTEE TO THE
CALIFORNIA. COASTAL COMMISSION
NEXT IS A FORMER MEMBER PAUL
THE KNIFE FROM GARDENA HE
SERVED FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE TO NINETEEN EIGHTY AFTER
BEING INTERNED AT MANZANAR
DURING WORLD WAR TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BUT NIGHT AND LISTED AND
TO THE UNITED STATES ARMY
SERVING WITH THE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY SECOND INFANTRY
REGIMENT AND THE ARMY
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE. HE WENT
ON TO BECOME THE FIRST JAPANESE
AMERICAN EVER TO SERVE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE I
NEXT WE HAVE PHIL WHY MEN FROM
TO HATCH BE. WHO SERVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY FROM SEVENTY EIGHT TO
NINETY TWO AND SERVED FROM
NINETY THREE TO NINETY FOUR AND
TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND FOUR
IN THE STATE SENATE. PHIL
WYMAN- HE SERVED EIGHTEEN YEARS
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE AND PRODUCT
LEGISLATURE HE SERVED THE
UNITED STATES AIR FORCE FROM
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE SO I ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THESE FORMER
MEMBERS. MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RICH COLOR ON MISS
SMITH YOUR RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
TODAY I RISE WITH A HEAVY HEART
AS NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH OF LAST
YEAR ONE OF MY HOME HIGH
SCHOOLS BECAME ANOTHER IN THE
SADLY LONG LIST OF SCHOOLS
STRUCK BY SCHOOL SHOOTINGS. I
RISE WITH A HEAVY HEART TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF TWO YOUNG
LIVES CUT MUCH TOO SHORT IN THE
SHOOTING AT SAUGUS HIGH SCHOOL
ON NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH. GRACIE
ANNUAL BURGER OF SAUGUS WAS
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD. SHE WAS
DESCRIBED BY HER FAMILY AS
VIVACIOUS FUNNY LOYAL AND THE
DAUGHTER WE ALWAYS DREAM TO
HAVE. FIERCELY STRONG AND A
LOVER OF ALL THINGS FASHIONABLE
SHE WAS OUR BEST FRIEND.
REFLECTING ON HIS DAUGHTER
GRACIE'S FATHER SAID SHE WAS
ABLE TO MAKE A LARGER IMPACT ON
MORE PEOPLE AND MORE
COMMUNITIES THAN MOST OF US
WILL IN A LIFETIME. DOMINIC
BLACKWELL OF SAUGUS WAS
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD. HE WAS THE
OLDEST OF FOUR SONS AND WAS
QUOTE A KID WITH AN INFECTIOUS
LAUGH A BRIGHT SMILE AND A KIND
HEART. DOMINIC WAS A MEMBER OF
THE ROTC A FOOTBALL PLAYER AND
HE LOVES SWIMMING. DOMINIC'S
GRANDMOTHER SAID HE WAS A
STRAIGHT A STUDENT WHO LIKE TO
DRAW. DOMINIC WAS VERY AGILE
AND FULL OF JOY AND LIFE HE WAS
HELPFUL AND HE TREATED PEOPLE
WITH RESPECT. AT A CELEBRATION
OF HIS LIFE DOMINIC'S
GRANDFATHER RECOUNTED HE WAS
HIS MOM'S LITTLE PAIN NOT.
THEIR LOSS IS DEVASTATING. AND
THE VIOLENCE LEAVES AN ENORMOUS
VOID IN OUR COMMUNITY. I ASKED
THAT WE A JOINT RETURN IN THEIR
MEMORY. AND THAT WE HOLD THEM
AND THE OTHER STUDENTS WHO WERE
WOUNDED THEIR FAMILIES THE
SAGAS HIGH SCHOOL COMMUNITY AND
OUR SANTA CLARITA COMMUNITY IN
OUR HEARTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS SMITH. MR GLORIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE THIS AFTERNOON
TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF JOANNE CLIMBING.
JOANNE WAS BORN ON APRIL
THIRTEENTH NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
AND PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER
ELEVENTH TWENTY NINETEEN SHE
WAS EIGHTY YEARS OLD. WHEN IS A
GRADUATE OF THE SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND SHE SPENT HER
CAREER- IN PUBLIC EDUCATION AS
A TEACHER. AS SUCH SHE WAS A
LONG TIME MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL EDUCATION ASSOCIATION.
WAS OFTEN JOANNE'S WORK OUTSIDE
OF THE CLASSROOM AS SOMEONE WHO
IS HIGHLY INVOLVED IN COMMUNITY
AND POLITICAL AFFAIRS IN THE
SAN DIEGO AREA AND BEYOND. SHE
SERVED AS AN EXECUTIVE MEMBER
OF THE CITY OR COUNTY DEMOCRATS
FOR A QUALITY OUR LOCAL LGBT Q.
DEMOCRATIC CLUB SHE WAS ELECTED
MEMBER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
CENTRAL COMMITTEE. SHE WAS A
STATE PARTY DELEGATE A REGIONAL
DIRECTOR AND A NATIONAL
DELEGATE TO THE DNC. SUFFICE TO
SAY I DON'T THINK I EVER SAW
JOANNE WITHOUT A BUTTON THE
STICKER A LANYARD OR SOMETHING
OF SOME KIND ATTACHED TO HER
WHEN I RECALL JOANNE YOU COULD
ALWAYS BE COUNTED ON. TO HAVE A
VERY THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION
WITH SOMEBODYDEEPLY CARED
ABOUT ISSUES AND WAS ALWAYS
LOOKING TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
THROUGHOUT SAN DIEGO JOANNE IS
KNOWN AS A FIERCE RENOWN
ACTIVISTS FOR WOMEN FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND FOR THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. AS A LIFETIME MEMBER
OF THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
FOR WOMEN JOANNE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A SAN DIEGO
AREA CHAPTER OF THE
ORGANIZATION A CHAPTER THAT IS
STILL HIGHLY ACTIVE TODAY.
JOANNE WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED BY HER COUNTLESS
STUDENTS THAT SHE TAUGHT AND
THAT SHE MENTORED WHO'VE GONE
ON TO DO AMAZING THINGS
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY. AND
CONSISTENTWILLINGNESS TO BE TO
FIGHT FOR A BETTER PRESENT IN
FUTURE FOR ALL PEOPLE. IS
WITHOUT QUESTION THE JOANNE'S
LIFE TIME A SERVICE TO OUR
COMMUNITY MADE A DIFFERENCE SHE
HELPED USHER AND MORE JUST
INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE
POLICIES THAT LEADS TO A BETTER
SOCIETY THAT WE ALL GET TO
ENJOY TODAY. IN FACT MISTER
SPEAKER SHE CLEARLY LEFT THE
WORLD BETTER THAN SHE FOUND IT.
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS AND SO
MANY MORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE ADJOURNED
IN THE MEMORY OF JOANNE
CLIMBING. GOD SPEED JOANNE.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA. MISS
GONZALES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF THE HARI JEFFERS HARDY IS
BEST KNOWN FOR HELPING FOUND
THE UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS THE
FIRST HOME HEALTHCARE WORKERS
UNION IN THE NATION ALONG WITH
HER HUSBAND CAN SETON M. AS IN
SAM MARGIE. THROUGH THEIR HARD
WORK WHAT STARTED WITH MEETINGS
IN SOUTHEAST SAN DIEGO WITH
JUST A HUNDRED AND FIFTY PEOPLE
GREW INTO AN ORGANIZATION TODAY
REPRESENTING OVER SEVENTY
THOUSAND WORKERS HEIDI WAS BORN
IN SAN DIEGO ON MAY EIGHTH
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR. SHE
ORIGINALLY HAD DROPPED OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL BUT LATER WENT ON
TO FINISH HER HIGH SCHOOL
DEGREE EARNED A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN PSYCHOLOGY FROM SAN
DIEGO STATE A MASTERS IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION FROM NATIONAL
UNIVERSITY AND A LAW DEGREE
FROM THOMAS JEFFERSON SCHOOL OF
LAW. WHEN SHE BEGAN ORGANIZING
DOMESTIC WORKERS IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES THEIR
STORIES ABOUT HER JUST SIMPLY
RIDING THE BUS BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN SOUTH SAN DIEGO AND THE
WHOLE IDEA. AS DOMESTIC WORKERS
GOT ON AND OFF THE BUS AND SHE
WOULD TALK TO THEM ABOUT THEIR
LIVELIHOODS AND WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AND WHAT WAS MISSING.
SHE WAS INSPIRED AND GUIDED BY
THE WORK OF SENSOR CHAVEZ. EVEN
AFTER RETIRING FROM UT W. I'M
BATTLING MEDICAL ISSUES
INCLUDING A BRAIN ANEURYSM IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR. HOW DO YOU
CONTINUE TO BE INVOLVED IN HER
COMMUNITY IN NATIONAL CITY.
THROUGH VARIOUS VOLUNTEER
POSITIONS AND COMMUNITY GROUPS
SHE CONTINUED WITH HER
PARTICIPATION AND LABOR AND SHE
WALKED A WHOLE LOT OF
PRECINCTS. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SHE WAS INDUCTED INTO SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WOMEN'S HALL OF FAME FOR
HER OUTSTANDING CONTRIBUTIONS
TO COMMUNITY. HOW DO YOU DIED
ON OCTOBER THIRTIETH AT THE AGE
OF SIXTY FIVE. SHE IS SURVIVED
BY HER HUSBAND FIVE CIVILIANS.
AND HER SIXTEEN ADOPTED
CHILDREN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEY AND THE MEMORY OF A
HOTTIE JEFFERS. FAMOUS GONZALES.
AND DOCTOR WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
ASK ME DURING THE MEMORY OF
MIKE RILEY RESIDENT OF
FORESTVILLE FORMER CINEMA
COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND A FORMER
COASTAL COMMISSION CHAIR. ASKED
TO WAIT THE DAY AFTER CHRISTMAS
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY FIVE
AFTER HAVING BEEN DIAGNOSED
WITH A LS. MIKE WAS AN
UNWAVERING ADVOCATE FOR THE
LOWER RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED.
HE WAS OF THE LIBERAL
PERSUASION- HIS BACKGROUND WAS
ALWAYS ABOUT PEOPLE WORKING IN
HUMAN SERVICES BEFORE HE WON A
VACANCY ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX. FOR TWELVE YEARS HE
ADVOCATED FOR HIS CONSTITUENTS
AND TO PROTECT THE LAND IN THE
COASTLINE. IN KEEPING WITH HIS
PASSION SERVED ON THE STATE
COASTAL COMMISSION FOR TWELVE
YEARS TWO YEARS AS ITS CHAIR
AND ALSO ON THE BOARD OF THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL CONSERVANCY.
IS PASSIONATE ABOUT HIS WORK
AND ALWAYS CAME WELL PREPARED
STUDIES PACKETS WORKING
UNDERSTAND THE IS THE
INTRICACIES OF THE ASPECTS OF
EVERY ISSUE. IS VERY DOWN TO
EARTH HONEST KIND ANY ALWAYS
SPOKE HIS MIND. HIS LEADERSHIP
EMERGING HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR
CLASS PRESIDENT IF HE WERE HIGH
AND THEN AS A STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT AT SHOULD BOW
COLLEGE. HE CO FOUNDED AND
DIRECTED PROJECT EATEN A
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDED DRUG
COUNSELING AND OTHER SERVICES
TO YOUTH IN CRISIS HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN RIVER
SWITCHBOARD A GRASSROOTS HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY THAT LATER
BECAME WEST COUNTY COMMUNITY
SERVICES WHICH IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TODAY. AMONG THE OPEN
SPACE PROJECTS THAT BEAR
RILEY'S FINGERPRINTS ARE THE
FIVE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY ACRE JENNER HEAVENS
PRESERVE. AND THE WEST COUNTY
TRAIL. IS PUBLIC SERVICE ALSO
INCLUDED TERMS ON THE FORCE
BILL IN WEST COMMUNITY WAS
COUNT EXCUSE ME HIGH SCHOOL
BOARD. HE WAS A MILITARY
VETERAN OF THE ARMY. HE MARRIED
HIS WIFE JUDY WALKER NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN AS
YOU TRAVEL WITH HIM ON MANY OF
HIS WORK RELATED JOURNEY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. IN
ADDITION TO HIS WIFE JUDY MIKE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS BROTHER
TERRY RILEY OF BACK OF BILL.
HIS DAUGHTERS KIMBERLY TILTON
OF SANTA ROSA SHERRI MANION.
AND NUMEROUS NIECES NEPHEWS
GRANNIES HIS GRAND NEPHEWS. WE
SENT OUR SYMPATHIES TO JUDY IN
THE AND THE REST OF THE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS MIKE MADE A
DIFFERENCE. AND WILL MISS HIM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES OF THE DESTINY PRINT IN
THE JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS TO
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED. IN THE
JOURNAL. MEMBERS I BELIEVE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN BURKE. HAS GUEST
THAT ARRIVED IN THE CHAMBER IS
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AND
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF THE
EMERALD AGENTS ARE HERE IN THE
GALLERY FOR THEIR LEGISLATIVE
DAY WORLD AGENTS ARE TAX
SPECIALISTS. THAT REPRESENTS
TAXPAYERS BEFORE THE IRS AND
HANDLE ALL THINGS TACTLESS
WELCOME THEM TO THE CAPITAL
PLEASE. MEMBERS MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY JANUARY
SEVENTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY JANUARY. SECOND
SESSION THURSDAY JANUARY NINTH
FLOOR SESSION. IS AT NINE A. M.
ALL OUR OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WE PASS RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
WE CONTINUE. SEEING AND HEARING
A FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. TO ADJOURN
MISTER CHOLERA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS. THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY JANUARY NINTH. AT NINE
AM FORM CALL IS LIFTED